i the undersigned foodie returning
officer at the election held on thursday
the seventh of me 2015 do hereby give
notice that the number of votes for each
candidate that the election is as
follows steven andrew communist party
119 Paul bomb field labor party twenty
four thousand three hundred
Elizabeth bring English Democrats
putting England first 68 Tom Brown the
above and beyond 40 42 dominic coke UK
3296 Jillian Creasy Green Party 6999
Michael Robert driver workers
Revolutionary Party 33 and a hassle
pirate 4113 Jill otten Liberal Democrats
4278 Stephanie row the Conservative
Party candidate 4917 then the
the number of ballot papers rejected
were as follows 199 and I thereby hereby
declared it Paul Bloomfield has been
duly elected to represent
can I can I first thank the returning
officer and all his staff all the police
and everybody who's been involved in the
administration of the election today I'm
delighted it's a slightly earlier
results than it was five years ago can I
also thank my agent Barney my knots who
has been what has worked with me over
the last seven years and was so crucial
in winning in 2010 ins been so crucial
in winning today along with all of a
fantastic campaign team it has been an
extraordinary privilege to be a
candidate working alongside Labour Party
members in Sheffield central in this
election but above all can I thank the
people of Sheffield central who have
transformed a majority five years ago of
165 into majority of 17,000 309
it has it's been an extraordinary
privilege over the last five years to
represent the city that I've lived and
worked in for most of my life in
Parliament but by equal measure it has
been distressing to see the impact of
this government's policies and
particularly on the most vulnerable in
the constituency I represent in the city
that I love and to see funding taken
away from our city and redistributed by
this government to wealthier parts of
the country it says everything about the
Tories now while outside Sheffield labor
may not have made the advances that we
might have hoped tonight neither have
the conservatives won a majority and the
coalition parties it would seem on the
predictions that there are at the moment
will have less seats than they had in
the previous Parliament so they have no
mandate for more of the same policies
they have no mandate to continue their
failed and divisive policies and those
of us who are elected tonight to
represent labour and to represent
Sheffield as a label as Labour voices
within this Parliament that's coming up
we'll continue to challenge those
policies because we believe that Britain
can do better